nes breathalyzer and what's so great
about these balls ah Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow in Sonic CD don't make
the blue blur wait too long or
eventually he'll say I'm a game and he's
dead what Yoshi's Island contains the
zombie glitch watch the number of lives
[Music]
now work but the coolest undead bug is
this zombie ant infected by killer fungi
that controls its mind it moves it along
to an ideal place in the forest before
killing its host bursting through the
ants head and releasing spores oh and
the Pokemon Paris and Paris ex are
directly influenced by this creepy fungi
but the Goliath tigerfish might still be
creepier switching from nature to
technology controlling a robot with the
PlayStation Move is pretty cool but if
you prefer being more vocal with your
commands there is pew pew pew
this is a mic controlled shooting and it
might strain your voice after a while so
have a nice glass of water that way what
this is actually normal water dissolving
a spoon made of gallium you can make
your own disappearing spoon by following
the link below dog Brella blue whale
heart if you haven't seen these yet
their fan are dedicated to D mix of
modern games like Super Smash Brothers
Brawl Guitar Hero and Final Fantasy 13
what you think of that world's fattest
contortionist that's what I thought
here's a dubstep dance routine direct
from France check this out
it is impossible
and finally a short film on stashing
your stuff
[Music]
it raises the question do you have a
secret hiding spot I'm gonna leave you
with a riddle to fathers and two sons
walk into a pet store they buy three
dogs each person gets a dog how is that
possible leave your answer in the
comments below
and we're going to do the genius of the
week a little different this time give
us your best mind-blowing fact and
whoever has the highest rated comment is
our genius of the week good luck and as
always thanks for watching
you